the cowboys one of the worst teams this
year are going to be looking for all
sorts of cures
in 2021 a couple of things said today by
stephen jones the cowboys coo and let me
tell you at a time when
there isn't a whole lot of information
flowing because of the covet 19
protocols and there is an open locker
room and there isn't jerry jones holding
quarter after the game
the cowboys still do a good job of
filling the void
one day it's stephen the next day it's
jerry then it's stephen then it's jerry
today it's stephen
as it usually is on mondays he was asked
about the possibility of the cowboys
having one of the top picks in the 2021
draft and oh
oh they're on track for that and he was
asked if they would consider taking a
quarterback said stephen jones
dax our quarterback we're so fired up
about him
and him leading us into the future now
look
i hope he's lying not not that they
don't want dak but i hope that the truth
is
for the sake of the cowboys organization
and all the fans out there i hope the
truth is they will evaluate
all options because that's what every
team
must do sharing you can't take off the
table the possibility of drafting trevor
lawrence or justin fields or some other
quarterback
by the time we get to april and we know
who the best candidates are
you can't just say we're not going to do
that you need to have
everyone guessing you need to have dak
guessing
you need to have the players who may be
picked guessing
you because there's a chance you're
gonna be able to trade that pick to
somebody who wants a quarterback
you don't want to be on record saying we
don't want that quarterback because
sometimes your best trade leverage is
maybe we'll just take them ourselves so
look i
i understand they're trying to create a
certain image and paint a certain
picture about the cowboys organization
at a time when there aren't many
positive things to be said or done
but i hope like hell that for their sake
they will explore all options when the
time comes if they end up with one of
the top picks and as of right now it
looks like they
will yeah they're a top five pick right
now mike and and if you're in that
position i
i think you have to look at those
quarterbacks you have to there there's
just no
if ands and buts about it you have to
take a look at them especially since
your franchise quarterback is playing
under the franchise tag and he is
unsigned for next year i think that puts
you
firmly in a position to have to look at
those quarterbacks
and say if we can't get this guy signed
can we afford
dak prescott under the franchise tag
next season
or do we move on to somebody else who is
going to cost
way less money and roll our dice that
justin fields or trevor lawrence is
better than dak prescott coming off an
injury when we don't know how he's going
to be because he will not have worked
out
at that point stephen jones said doc's
ahead of
his recovery schedule about four months
it was supposed to take
so we'll see where he is but they're not
going to know a whole lot about his
condition
before they have to make a decision on
the franchise tax so i think that puts
them in a very difficult position and
they need to keep all
options on the table as you said mike
here's the reality
as it relates to dak prescott unless
there is some broader renegotiation of
the cba that changes the way that the
franchise tag is calculated
for a player who has a salary that
guarantees him at a minimum a 20 percent
raise
over what his cap number was the prior
year and that's unlikely even with the
salary cap likely plummeting to 175
million
the cowboys are looking at 37 million
plus next year to tag
prescott again with the cap dropping to
175
i guarantee you 37 million for one year
with dak
is more than what they would pay the
number one overall pick
for four years combined that
has to be part of the consideration if
you're the cowboys if you end up with
one of those top picks
and if you believe that one of those
quarterbacks
can be as good just as good just
almost as good as dak makes it dollar
for dollar
a much better deal to go with the
younger player and you finally solve
this problem that you the cowboys
created by not getting dak
signed sooner another problem the
cowboys created in the eyes of many of
their fans hiring mike mccarthy to be
the head coach
said stephen jones when asked whether
mccarthy will be the coach in 2021
absolutely unequivocal and look
he can say whatever he wants in november
of a failing
season if they would fire mike mccarthy
after the season ends and i'm not saying
they will
i'm not saying they should but the last
thing anyone is going to do
is pull up this quote from november 9
2020 and say ah-ha you said
absolutely unequivocal mike mccarthy
will be back and you fired him so
so what do you well what are you gonna
do nobody cares at that point so i
it's just air it's just noise and i'm
not complaining
shireen it gives us stuff to talk about
but to me
this assessment is meaningless to mike
mccarthy's future because if they stink
for the rest of the year
it has to be on the table that he may be
gone
yeah two things mike he also said jerry
jones said not stephen jones but jerry
jones said
uh back before he fired wade phillips
when wade phillips was under fire
jerry jones pointed out i've never fired
a head coach in the middle of a season
it's not gonna happen now and i'm
paraphrasing but that was basically it
and he said it multiple times so what
happens
they go lay egg against green bay and
what does he do the next day he fires
wade phillips so anything's on the table
as we know
absolutely mike and we probably will
pull the quote back out and say they did
give him a vote of confidence but
they decided you know after the season
changed their minds people do change
their minds but i do think mike
mccarthy's
is back i thought i saw progress with
the team yesterday
the defense played much better than they
have played so maybe mike nolan is
making progress on that defense and
and they made some changes and they put
some young guys in there and they really
played well
so we'll see what happens the rest of
the season i think it's really important
and steven jones also talked about this
today
really important for them to establish
mike mccarthy's culture what he wants
what he's asking and they can do that
the rest of the year
they're not going to the playoffs
they're not going to win the nfc east
even though they're still in the race
let's be realistic about this
they've started four quarterbacks but
they can establish some things the rest
of the season and build toward
2021. best example of why we should put
no stock in what stephen jones said
about mike mccarthy it was during the
2010
season wade phillips was in jeopardy and
jerry jones was constantly being
harassed
shireen with the question of whether or
not he would fire wade phillips during
the season he had never fired a coach
during the season i'm never going to do
that i'm not going to do it i'm not
going to do it then they get blown out
by the packers and they're embarrassed
in the process and he fires wade
phillips and
and who cares if he previously said
that the last thing he would do is fire
wade phillips during the season but that
gives
coaches gm's executives owners
no real credibility it creates headlines
it gives us things to talk about
at the end of the day it's worthless
because they can change their minds
whenever however and wherever they want
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports